(audience applaud)
Oh, I'm so excited!
I love him, please welcome Jason Derulo!
(audience cheering)
Hey there, how are you doing?
Oh my gosh, I have been such a fan of yours
for a long time and I'm just so happy
for each and every one of your successes,
may I start with that?
Oh thank you, likewise the same, same!
Thank you.
I mean, you're such a famous singer,
and then you decide to get on TikTok,
you wanna innovate, you wanna raise the game
and make it interesting.
44 million followers!
Unprecedented, a billion likes!
(Jason laughing)
I appreciate that, thank you.
Now you have these things called milli meals.
Will you tell me about that?
Uh huh.
Yeah so I started off
as me trying different recipes 'cause we at home
and I didn't, I had to figure out
where to put my creativity, and I've never been a cook.
So this is definitely something new
that happened in the pandemic.
So what I started doing is put all of my favorite things
into one dish and (laughing) then I started
calling them milli meals.
And I told the fans that every time that I reached
a new million, I would do some kind of recipe.
But I didn't imagine that it was gonna be
every week or so.
Now, we love to try celebrity-approved
weird food combos on our show,
it's sort of a running theme we have,
and I was wondering if you would be up
to try some of them with us?
Oh absolutely, this is my favorite thing to do.
All right, well we can't have a weird foods tasting
without our friend and culinary contributor,
he's also in the million follower TikTok club,
it's Eitan Bernath.
(audience clapping)
Hello!
Hi Drew, Hi Jason I am so excited to be here.
Hey Eitan, how you doing?
By the way, Jason just took his shirt off
and got ready to eat so I'm excited.
I'm going to leave my shirt on and eat.
Are you Eitan?
Yes.
I was gonna take my vest off.
Okay we're getting comfy.
Well, I'm really excited Eitan is gonna be sharing
two celebrity approved weird dishes,
and he always brings it.
And then Jason, as the third and final step,
is gonna teach us how to make something.
Jason, whoa I'm not gonna lie, I'm scared.
Me too.
And just stick around,
'cause you won't wanna miss it,
it's a salmon smoothie.
Words I, I never, I don't think those words
need to be together, but they are.
I don't know if my gag reflexes are gonna
let this happen but I'm going to try it,
'cause that's how much I love you Jason,
I'm really excited.
Also look at you, you just.
Clearly it works.
Tell me what I need to do,
And I'll do it!
He's all shredded, I mean.
Eitan, take it away what's our first weird food combo?
Okay awesome, so first up we are going to be having
something from Channing Tatum.
"People" magazine reported that he likes to have
peanut butter jelly and Cheetos sandwiches.
Now, he has very specific instructions.
It's a normal amount of peanut butter,
then you ready for this?
Take your Cheetos and you're going to crush them
onto the peanut butter, all right?
I see Jason's making his.
And he also specifies that you put the Cheetos
on the peanut butter and then the jelly on top of that.
Well, because the peanut butter is kind of an adhesive.
Yes
Jason, are you excited to try this weird food combo?
Oh, I think this one is actually gonna be good,
for some reason.
Are you going whole, Jason? Or are you cutting?
Nah, I'm gonna take the whole thing down.
Perfect, us too okay are you ready?
Yep
One, two, here we go.
Oh I love the crunch.
Wow.
Oh wow, now I'm getting to the Cheetos, whoa.
(audience laughs)
This, there's only one way
you come up with this recipe.
High?
Yes.
(audience laughs)
(audience applauds)
Wow, it's not bad.
(audience clap)
I'll give that a 9 out of 10.
Now, next up Jason and Drew,
we have, according to "The Huffington Post,"
Beyonce, when she was pregnant with Blue Ivy,
dipped bananas into ketchup.
All right.
Now to be fair to Beyonce,
'cause we don't want to offend the queen bee,
but she denies these rumors .
But regardless, I feel like we have to try it.
Oh, that actually looks terrible
in that display right there.
That that display is terrible.
By the way, you're right.
It is totally like murder on the old banana express.
It looks like a spider.
You know what it is? It's like a shrimp.
Oh my God, it's like the cocktail shrimp.
My God, it's like a shrimp cocktail!
A cocktail shrimp.
Yes.
Oh, definitely.
It's banana cocktail.
On your marks, get set, dip.
(Eitan grunts disapprovingly)
All right, here we go.
Oh my God.
I don't like to eat my bananas
like that, I aint gonna lie.
I'm gonna take it all.
Oh!
(audience laugh)
(audience clap)
Ew!
Thank you.
Oh my gosh!
(Drew laughs)
I'm gonna be right back.
Jason has left the studio, that's a no from me.
That was disgusting.
Sorry guys.
No, Jason it's, you know what?
It's a good tee up.
To this one?
(Jason laughs)
Okay, Jason take us through something
I've been thinking about for weeks
in anticipation of this segment.
So, this is 'sposed to be a meal replacement, right?
So by blending the salmon, it kind of eliminates
the chewing and then it's liquid, right?
So it's easily digestible.
Okay, so salmon, you put water in there,
eight ounces of water.
Tabasco.
Yeah, this is pretty bad.
I saw some Tabasco,
I'm the most excited about this.
Okay.
I mean, okay here we go, all right.
These, okay we're gonna put aside, perfect.
Okay, ready?
Here we go.
One.
(Eitan gagging)
Oh my.
It's actually not bad.
How are you not spiting that out?
(audience clapping)
That deserves a round of applause.
That's better than banana with ketchup for sure.
You know what?
I will tell you something,
it's better than the banana and the ketchup.
(Jason laughing)
Oh my gosh you guys, this was the most fun,
weird food combos we've ever done.
Yes
I can't thank you enough Eitan,
always you are my partner in weird food combo crime,
and the culinary world in general.
(upbeat music)